This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Andrew Blum is a journalist who writes about some of the biggest infrastructure projects in the world. His specialty is revealing how systems we think of as intangible like the internet are actually made up of very real stuff. The internet relies on cables and wires and data centers, which are maintained by actual people who keep the whole thing running. A few years back, Andrew got interested in the weather forecast.
这里是99% Invisible，我是Roman Mars。Andrew Blum是一位报道全球大型基础设施项目的记者。他的专长是揭示那些我们认为无形的系统（比如互联网）实际上是由非常实在的东西构成的。互联网依赖于电缆、电线和数据中心，这些设施由真实的人员维护，以保持整个系统的运行。几年前，Andrew对天气预报产生了兴趣。
It's this mundane everyday service that, like the internet, is made possible by a vast and interconnected global machine that took decades to build. The system is a huge scientific project. But it's also a diplomatic one. The atmosphere crosses all political boundaries, and so knowing the weather requires international collaboration. As weather becomes more extreme, the forecast becomes increasingly important, but ironically, because of its growing value, there are now forces threatening to undermine the global system that makes it possible.
这是一种平凡的日常服务，就像互联网一样，它是由一个耗时数十年建立起来的庞大且相互关联的全球机器所实现的。这个系统是一个巨大的科学工程，但它同时也是一个外交工程。大气层跨越了所有的政治边界，因此了解天气需要国际间的合作。随着天气变得越来越极端，天气预报变得愈发重要，但讽刺的是，由于其价值的增长，现在出现了一些力量，威胁要破坏使这一切成为可能的全球系统。
It is fascinating stuff. I talked to Andrew about his book, The Weather Machine, and he told me that he first got interested in the forecast back in 2012. It was a kind of busy season for me. My first book had come out. My dog had died. My son was bored. It all kind of happened at once. And there was a weekend afternoon as kind of Sunday in October when I had my kind of new board in one hand and my phone and the other. And there was a weekend afternoon, a kind of Sunday in October, when I had my kind of newborn in one hand, and my phone and the other. And I was on Twitter. And all of a sudden, the meteorologists who I followed kind of went into a tizzy. They all just kind of erupted all at once, based on the output of a weather model. And what they were seeing
这真是令人着迷。我和Andrew聊了他的书《天气机器》（The Weather Machine），他告诉我，他是在2012年开始对天气预报产生兴趣的。那对我来说是一个忙碌的季节。我的第一本书出版了，我的狗死了，我的儿子很无聊，这一切似乎同时发生了。那是一个10月的周日下午，我一手抱着刚出生的孩子，另一手拿着手机。我当时在刷Twitter。突然间，我关注的气象学家们陷入了恐慌。他们几乎同时因为一个天气模型的输出结果而炸开了锅。他们所看到的是
was a storm that they had kind of been watching out in the Atlantic, in the Southern Atlantic, but suddenly it was going to turn left towards New York where I live. And it was remarkable because this was eight days ahead. This was a big storm potentially. And they all kind of trusted the output of this model. They weren't, you know, they weren't saying this is definitely going to happen, but it was so far ahead of sort of what I understood as the work of meteorologist, especially kind of hurricane forecasters.
一场他们一直在大西洋、南大西洋监测的风暴，但它突然要向左转，朝我居住的纽约袭来。这很了不起，因为这是提前八天预报的。这可能是一场大风暴。他们都信任这个模型的输出。他们并不是说这一定会发生，但这远超出了我所理解的气象学家的工作范畴，尤其是飓风预报员的工作。
Yeah. And this storm that you could kind of see eight days out eventually became hurricane sand. It is chaos along the Jersey shore. The super storm already stretching across one third of this country from Florida to Canada. I can't wait to see news. I covered New York weather for 25 years. I have never seen water in Lower Manhattan.
是的。你能在八天前看到的这场风暴最终变成了飓风桑迪。泽西海岸一片混乱。这场超级风暴已经横跨了从佛罗里达州到加拿大的全国三分之一地区。我简直不敢相信新闻。我报道纽约天气25年了，我从未见过曼哈顿下城被水淹没。
There is water now on the streets in Lower Manhattan. I mean, the overall feeling when the storm actually came was that our kind of luck had run out. That New York city had sort of finally begun to reckon with what the storms of the future might be like. With the subways flooded and shut down, nobody did anything for that week. Along the coast, it was months and years, and if you live on the L train, it's still being fixed.
现在曼哈顿下城的街道上有水了。我的意思是，当风暴真正来临时，整体的感觉是我们的运气用光了。纽约市终于开始正视未来的风暴可能会是什么样子。随着地铁被淹没和关闭，那一周没人能做任何事。在沿海地区，影响持续了数月甚至数年，如果你住在L线地铁沿线，它至今仍在维修中。
These are the consequences if it was really clear. I mean, 147 people were killed. But when it came, for me, it was a recognition that that forecast eight days ago was right. That an eight day forecast is not stuff of science fiction, but had just happened in the most consequential way. And the real difference here between the idea of knowing a thing that's coming in the way that knowing a cold front is coming or knowing that a tornado is coming is like Hurricane Sandy didn't exist eight days before. It was just particles in the atmosphere moving around and it was a mathematical model that predicted that it would form into this thing that would affect people so dramatically.
如果说有什么是非常清楚的，那就是这些后果。有147人丧生。但对我来说，当它来临时，我意识到八天前的那个预报是正确的。八天的预报不是科幻小说，而是以最重大的方式发生了。这里真正的区别在于，了解即将发生的事情——比如知道冷锋要来或龙卷风要来——与飓风桑迪在八天前并不存在是不同的。它当时只是大气中移动的粒子，是一个数学模型预测它会形成这种对人们产生如此巨大影响的东西。
I mean, the experience of Sandy made me want to know not only what the weather models were, but where they came from, sort of who built them, how they had evolved over time. I mean, I recognize them as this kind of complex global infrastructure, but as is often the case with complex global infrastructures, their authorship was really vague and longstanding. Right. And so, you know, you've spent a lot of time
我的意思是，桑迪的经历让我不仅想知道天气模型是什么，还想知道它们来自哪里，是谁建造了它们，以及它们是如何随时间演变的。我意识到它们是一种复杂的全球基础设施，但正如复杂的全球基础设施通常的情况一样，它们的作者身份非常模糊且由来已久。没错。所以，你花了很多时间
thinking about physical infrastructure, and there's something about the weather forecast that kind of has this vibe of face-about mathematical models and physics and stuff in the air, but it still really is rooted in infrastructure. It kind of dovetailed with the thing that you already care about. So like, what is the modern weather machine actually physically look like? Well, to kind of see it like that, you kind of have to have this hallucination about, you know, a sort of planetary scale. It's made up of so many kind of tens of thousands of tiny little pieces.
思考物理基础设施，天气预报有一种关于数学模型、物理学和空气中事物的氛围，但它确实植根于基础设施。它与你已经关心的事物相吻合。那么，现代天气机器在物理上到底是什么样子的呢？嗯，要那样看待它，你必须对行星尺度有一种幻觉。它是由成千上万个微小的部分组成的。
I always like when you're flying out of LaGuardia Airport in New York, if you're lucky, you kind of pass by the weather station there by the runway. And it looks like a kind of jumble of equipment. And that's one piece of the weather machine. When we see satellite pictures, the kind of jumble of equipment, and that's one piece of the weather machine. You know, when we see satellite pictures, you know, the kind of familiar weather satellites, it's kind of another piece of the weather machine. And then that's repeated, you know,
我总是喜欢在纽约拉瓜迪亚机场起飞时，如果幸运的话，你会经过跑道旁边的气象站。它看起来像是一堆杂乱的设备。那是天气机器的一部分。当我们看到卫星图片时，那些熟悉的各种气象卫星，那是天气机器的另一部分。然后这被重复了
tens of thousands of times all over the world. Yeah. So as you started looking at the history of the weather forecast, now it started. You found that it was actually a revolution in telecommunications that made the first weather forecast possible. So tell me why the development of the telegraph was important for understanding the weather.
成千上万次，遍布世界各地。是的。所以当你开始研究天气预报的历史时，你发现正是电信革命使得第一次天气预报成为可能。那么请告诉我，为什么电报的发展对于理解天气很重要。
It's really about having this picture of the Earth across space. We have maps, that's kind of one way of imagining the Earth, but until you can communicate instantaneously across distance, you know, basically until you can communicate instantaneously across distance, basically until you have the telegraph and then all of the communications technology that comes after it, you can't really know what's happening simultaneously in many places all at once.
这实际上是关于在空间上拥有地球的图像。我们有地图，这是一种想象地球的方式，但在你能跨越距离进行即时通信之前，基本上在你有电报以及随之而来的所有通信技术之前，你无法真正知道许多地方同时发生了什么。
And it turns out the first step towards knowing what the weather is gonna be in one place at many times is knowing what the weather is at one time in many places. It's the kind of key to it. And so you end up as soon as the telegraph is invented, and as soon as there's a kind of rudimentary telegraph network, the telegraph operators begin sending messages to each other about the weather conditions. And they quickly realize that especially in the US, the weather is often moving from west
事实证明，了解一个地方在多个时间的天气情况的第一步，是了解多个地方在同一时间的天气情况。这是关键所在。所以，一旦电报被发明，一旦有了初步的电报网络，电报员就开始互相发送关于天气状况的信息。他们很快意识到，特别是在美国，天气通常是从西
to east, and they can give some advanced notice of what's going to happen that afternoon, based on, you know, if you're in New York, what is doing in Ohio? And that just kind of basic sense that you could move faster than the clouds, that the news could move faster than the clouds, begins to open up this idea of a kind of holistic view of the planet. Suddenly, you can kind of imagine yourself looking down, not just on a map as a political idea, but really live seeing how the weather is changing over space.
向东移动的，他们可以根据如果你在纽约，俄亥俄州的天气如何，来提前预告那天下午会发生什么。那种你可以比云移动得更快、新闻可以比云移动得更快的基本感觉，开始开启了一种对地球的整体观。突然间，你可以想象自己俯瞰，不仅仅是作为一种政治概念的地图，而是真正实时地看到天气是如何在空间上变化的。
And so in the 1840s, the Smithsonian Institute takes this sort of grand theoretical idea and turns it into an actual map, which is a kind of beautiful quirky analog fun thing that I loved your description of. Could you describe the map and how it functioned? Yeah, I mean, as with any corporate or government headquarters, when they built their new building, the centerpiece in the lobby of the Smithsonian Institution on the Mall in Washington was a big map of the, you know, fledgling United States up on the wall, pre-civil war 1840s. And whenever they got a report in from their
所以在19世纪40年代，史密森尼学会将这种宏大的理论构想变成了一张实际的地图，这是一种美丽、古怪、有趣的模拟装置，我很喜欢你的描述。你能描述一下这张地图以及它是如何运作的吗？是的，就像任何企业或政府总部一样，当他们建造新大楼时，位于华盛顿广场的史密森尼学会大厅的中心是一张巨大的地图，展示了19世纪40年代内战前羽翼未丰的美国。每当他们收到来自
Smithsonian observers, their kind of brand new network of weather observers, they would put a little paper disc up, and the disc would be, have the temperature, it would be, have a different color for the weather, so white for fair weather, you know, black for rain, brown for clouds, blue for snow, and so when you arrived at the Smithsonian, you could look up at the wall and you could see what the weather was across the country. And you could begin to have that first inference of the weather of the future, you know, the forecast based on how those patterns might be changing. Yeah.
史密森尼观测员（他们那种全新的天气观测员网络）的报告时，他们就会放一个小纸盘，纸盘上会有温度，会有不同的颜色代表天气，白色代表晴天，黑色代表雨天，棕色代表多云，蓝色代表雪天。所以当你到达史密森尼学会时，你可以抬头看墙，看到全国各地的天气。你可以开始对未来的天气进行最初的推断，也就是基于这些模式可能如何变化的预报。是的。
So then we get to the 1870s when there's an international coalition forming to expand the weather forecast. And people are starting to think about how to collect and share weather data more widely. I mean, from the beginnings of essentially international networks of any kind, you know, in the 1870s, you have international telegraph networks, the postal union is formed, you have the meter convention, you know, it's this kind of really vogue for standardization. And a big part of that is the recognition that if you have
所以我们到了19世纪70年代，当时有一个国际联盟正在形成，旨在扩大天气预报范围。人们开始考虑如何更广泛地收集和共享天气数据。我的意思是，从本质上讲，任何形式的国际网络之初，在19世纪70年代，你有了国际电报网络，万国邮政联盟成立了，你有了米制公约，这是一种非常流行的标准化趋势。其中很大一部分是认识到，如果你有
brand new national weather services, they need a common language for communicating their observations with each other. And we're each going to maybe make our own forecasts, but certainly knowing what the sky is in your country is useful to my country. And that kind of basic sense of meteorology is a common good of the Earth's atmosphere is continuous. It really becomes part of meteorological culture
全新的国家气象服务机构，他们需要一种共同的语言来交流观测结果。我们每个人可能都会做出自己的预报，但了解你所在国家的天空情况对我的国家肯定是有用的。这种气象学是地球大气层共同财富的基本感觉是连续的。它确实成为了气象文化的一部分
from the beginning. They are very good from a very early stage at cooperating with each other. Yeah, and so it becomes as much a diplomatic project as a scientific one. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. So how do people go from gathering data about the weather to actually doing something about it?
从一开始就是这样。他们从很早的阶段就非常擅长相互合作。是的，所以它既是一个外交项目，也是一个科学项目。是的，绝对是。那么人们是如何从收集天气数据转变为真正采取行动的呢？
Where do they actually start to look into the future of what was to come? Well, the first person who kind of codified the process that has become the weather models as we know them today was a Norwegian meteorologist named Wilhelm Björknes. And it was in the 1890s that he first began to play around with the idea that you could treat the weather forecast as a hypothesis, as a kind of mathematical hypothesis, that if you could calculate the weather, if you could calculate the evolution of the atmosphere, you know, temperature, its pressure, its wind direction, and you could do that mathematically, then you could be quite sure the next day if you were right or wrong. And if you were wrong, you could begin to refine your equations and then do it again the
他们到底是从哪里开始展望未来的？嗯，第一个将我们今天所知的气象模型过程编纂成法的人是一位名叫威廉·比耶克内斯（Vilhelm Bjerknes）的挪威气象学家。在19世纪90年代，他开始尝试将天气预报视为一种假设，一种数学假设：如果你能计算天气，如果你能计算大气的演变（温度、压力、风向），并且能通过数学方式做到这一点，那么你就能相当确定第二天你是对还是错。如果你错了，你可以开始改进你的方程，然后
next day, or you could even go back and use the previous day's observations and calculate it again. Right. But the mathematical models, how complex are they and how far in the future can he really look at this point? Well his basic equations, which are now kind of known in meteorology as the primitive equations, how much I kind of love, his basic equations were right, but he couldn't solve them. He neither had enough observations, especially at different levels of altitude, and high up into the atmosphere, nor could he solve the differential equations required to sort of solve his own equations.
第二天再做一次，或者你甚至可以回头使用前一天的观测数据重新计算。没错。但是这些数学模型有多复杂？他在这一点上真的能看到多远的未来？嗯，他的基本方程（现在在气象学中被称为原始方程，我非常喜欢这个名字）是对的，但他无法求解。他既没有足够的观测数据，特别是在不同高度和高层大气中的数据，也无法求解求解他自己方程所需的微分方程。
He couldn't actually plug the numbers in. So theoretically, he was mostly right, and in fact, the primitive equations are still at the root of the weather models. They're deep in there. They have evolved dramatically, but they're still there. They are still relevant. But practically, he got nowhere. He neither had enough to put into his math nor was he able to actually calculate what came out.
他实际上无法代入数字。所以从理论上讲，他大部分是正确的，事实上，原始方程仍然是天气模型的根基。它们深植其中。它们已经发生了巨大的演变，但它们仍然存在。它们仍然具有相关性。但在实践中，他一事无成。他既没有足够的数据输入到他的数学模型中，也无法真正计算出结果。
So then people can imagine these ways to get around this issue of the computation. So a mathematician named Louis Fry Richardson had this crazy idea that I want you to tell us about. Yeah. So, Bjorknis writes his paper in 1904, he says that we can predict the weather using math and physics. And about 10 years later, Louis Fry Richardson, an English mathematician, comes to it and says, well, I think I might actually give this a try.
所以人们可以想象出绕过计算问题的方法。一位名叫路易斯·弗莱·理查森（Lewis Fry Richardson）的数学家有一个疯狂的想法，我想让你告诉我们。是的。比耶克内斯在1904年发表了他的论文，他说我们可以利用数学和物理学来预测天气。大约10年后，英国数学家路易斯·弗莱·理查森接触到了这一点，并说，嗯，我想我可能真的要试一试。
And he actually uses a set of observations that Bureknaur himself would organize the collection of from a single day above Europe. And he begins this sort of furious six-week process of actually calculating that into a weather forecast. And he does it while he's working as an ambulance driver on the Western Front during World War I. Well, he was a quaker, so he wouldn't fight,'s working as an ambulance driver on the western front during World War I.
他实际上使用了一组比耶克内斯本人组织收集的欧洲某一天的数据。他开始了为期六周的疯狂过程，将这些数据计算成天气预报。他在第一次世界大战期间在西线担任救护车司机时完成了这项工作。嗯，他是一位贵格会教徒，所以他不参战，
Well, he was a quaker, so he wouldn't fight, but he drove an ambulance, and so he talks about going back to his billet and sort of running the calculations with his slide rule and spending six weeks on this sort of single afternoon's forecast, which famously and spectacularly was wrong, sort of famous errors in meteorology. But he was convinced that if he had better observations tactically was wrong, sort of famous errors in a meteorology.
但他开了救护车，所以他谈到回到驻地，用计算尺进行计算，花了六周时间做这个单一下午的预报，结果众所周知且极其错误，这是气象学中著名的错误。但他坚信，如果他有更好的观测数据，
But he was convinced that if he had better observations and if he had a greater ability to actually make these calculations, you could have a useful forecast. And he comes to the idea that what it would really take would be 64,000 computers, which is to say 64,000 humans, human computers, arranged in a stadium. And there would be a conductor in the middle who would shine a light on them if they were going too fast or too slow,
并且有更强的能力来进行这些计算，你就能得到有用的预报。他提出了一个想法，即真正需要的是64,000台计算机，也就是64,000个人类“计算机”，安排在一个体育场里。中间会有一个指挥，如果他们算得太快或太慢，他会用灯光照射他们，
and they would write their calculations and then pass it to the person next to them. And with 64,000 people, you could go fast enough to have a useful weather forecast, which is to say a forecast that is completed before the weather actually arrives. In one day. I mean, that's the thing. that is completed before the weather actually arrives. In one day. I mean, that's the thing. You know, you can have a very detailed forecast, but it's useless if the future comes before your calculations.
他们会写下计算结果，然后传给旁边的人。有了64,000人，你就可以足够快地得到有用的天气预报，也就是说，在天气真正到来之前完成预报。在一天之内。我的意思是，这就是重点。你知道，你可以有一个非常详细的预报，但如果未来在你的计算完成之前就到来了，那它是没用的。
Yeah. He also somewhat amazingly predicts like the Google campus. He thinks that like his 64,000 computers should have like ball fields and cafeterias and entertainment and things like that. And he also predicts like kind of steampunk aesthetic as well. He describes these offices with like levers and desks and things that rise up into roof decks and basically what Facebook is in Manlopark today.
是的。他还相当令人惊讶地预测了像谷歌园区这样的东西。他认为他的64,000台计算机应该有球场、自助餐厅、娱乐设施之类的东西。他还预测了一种蒸汽朋克美学。他描述了这些办公室，有杠杆和桌子，可以升到屋顶平台，基本上就是今天位于门洛帕克的Facebook总部。
Yeah, that's so funny. So we have these people thinking in these big ways about the weather and how to forecast it. And we have these couple of limitations that are they're budding up against. One is computational limitation. The other one is kind of data limitation, like access to these measuring these points. So how was weather forecasting moving forward
是的，太搞笑了。所以我们有这些人在以宏大的方式思考天气以及如何预报它。我们有他们正在碰壁的几个限制。一个是计算限制。另一个是数据限制，比如获取这些测量点。那么天气预报是如何向前发展的呢？
in the rest of the world? And what were they doing to come up with what was going to happen in the future? When Richard Sint and Björknis, when their project essentially fails, there's this kind of amazing and pretty successful, basically 40-year history of meteorology, that actually makes a lot of progress, whether forecast gets better and useful and helps with early aviation,
在世界其他地方？他们正在做什么来预测未来会发生什么？当理查森和比耶克内斯的项目基本上失败时，气象学经历了一段令人惊叹且相当成功的40年历史，实际上取得了很大进展，天气预报变得更好、更有用，并有助于早期航空业，
you know, most famously, you know, the forecast for D-Day was a solid two-day forecast that allowed the allies to postpone their invasion. It's sort of always pointed at us as kind of forecast that changed the course of history. But none of it had anything to do with these calculations. It's sort of the equivalent of looking at a cloud or a cold front and just seeing it go across the country and it has not a little math in it, but it has a lot of just history and past precedent and stuff that lets you predict what's going to happen in the future. Yeah, absolutely. And it wasn't until the post-war era when you have the beginnings of spaceflight and the beginnings of real computing that the idea of actually functionally creating a weather forecast based on mathematical analysis of the atmosphere becomes possible again.
最著名的是，诺曼底登陆的预报是一个可靠的两天预报，使盟军能够推迟入侵。它总是被我们视为改变历史进程的预报。但这一切都与这些计算无关。这相当于看着云或冷锋，看着它穿过全国，它几乎没有数学成分，但它有很多历史和过去的先例，让你能够预测未来会发生什么。是的，绝对是。直到战后时期，随着航天和真正计算技术的开始，基于大气数学分析来功能性地创建天气预报的想法才再次成为可能。
So after the war, we sort of get into the 50s and 60s and there's a big breakthrough. So new technologies emerge and there's a political will to build this whole earth map and make it really, really good. So tell us what happens in the 60s that makes jerkness's dream of calculating the weather finally come true. The most important thing is you have this kind of love affair with the earth, you know, with the earth as a planet. You know, you suddenly have this collective societal vision of what the earth will look
所以战后，我们进入了50年代和60年代，出现了一个重大突破。新技术出现了，并且有建立这张全地球地图并使其变得非常非常好的政治意愿。所以告诉我们60年代发生了什么，使得比耶克内斯计算天气的梦想最终成真。最重要的事情是你对地球有一种热爱，你知道，把地球作为一个行星。你突然有了一个集体的社会愿景，即地球从太空看起来会是什么样子。
like from space. You know, you have all this science fiction. You have the first people orbiting the earth and everyone's sort of imagining what it is like to look back. And as soon as you kind of have that in the popular imagination, the idea of a map of the complete atmosphere becomes real. We go into space because whatever mankind must undertake, free man must fully share. There's this incredible moment in 1961, right after the Soviets first launched Sputnik,
你知道，你有所有的科幻小说。你有第一批绕地球飞行的人，每个人都在想象回望地球是什么感觉。一旦你在大众想象中有了这种想法，完整大气层地图的想法就变得真实了。我们进入太空，因为无论人类必须承担什么，自由人必须充分分享。1961年有一个不可思议的时刻，就在苏联首次发射人造卫星之后，
where Kennedy gives a speech where he says, you know, have us put a man on the moon before the decade is out Provide the funds which are needed to meet the following national goals first I believe that this nation should commit itself to achieving the goal Before this decade is out of landing a man on the moon and returning him safely to the U.R. And that's point number one and turns out point number three is $75 million for weather satellites. Will help give us at the earliest possible time a satellite system for worldwide weather observation. Let it be clear. As familiar as that man in the moon line is, the line about weather satellites comes like 30 seconds later.
肯尼迪发表了一次演讲，他说，你知道，让我们在本十年结束前把人送上月球。提供实现以下国家目标所需的资金，首先我相信这个国家应该致力于实现这一目标，在本十年结束前，将一个人送上月球并让他安全返回。这是第一点，事实证明第三点是为气象卫星提供7500万美元。将帮助我们在最早的时间内为我们提供一个全球天气观测卫星系统。要明确的是，尽管“月球上的人”那句话很熟悉，但关于气象卫星的那句话是在30秒后出现的。
And for Kennedy, the global view of this was kind of part of the larger project of the triumph of American ideals around the globe otherwise. So you have this sort of moment where all of the kind of imperial ideals of a kind of American view of the globe and American dominance of the globe become wrapped up in a view of the atmosphere for scientific good, for meteorological good, for the sort of what we now think of as this banal project of creating better weather forecasts. So JK's vision came true in many ways.
对于肯尼迪来说，这种全球视野是美国理想在全球范围内取得胜利的更大项目的一部分。所以你有这样一个时刻，所有那种美国全球视野和美国全球主导地位的帝国理想，都包裹在为了科学利益、为了气象利益、为了我们现在认为的创建更好天气预报这种平庸项目而对大气层的观察中。所以比耶克内斯的愿景在许多方面都实现了。
Throughout the 60s and 70s, a lot of satellites went up into space, both for military surveillance and for weather forecasting. And as the weather machine grew, a worldwide alliance developed between nations. They figured out how to share data and how to maintain the infrastructure that they'd collectively build. The main part of the UN that now deals with weather is called the World Meteorological Organization, and they get together every four years to talk about policy, and Andrew went
在整个60年代和70年代，许多卫星被送入太空，既用于军事监视，也用于天气预报。随着天气机器的壮大，各国之间发展出了全球联盟。他们弄清楚了如何共享数据以及如何维护他们共同建立的基础设施。联合国现在处理天气的主要部分被称为世界气象组织，他们每四年聚在一起讨论政策，而Andrew去了
to one of these gatherings. Yeah, in 2015 in Geneva, the World Minerological Congress is the big event every four years, and it's the world's weather diplomats coming together, and sort of methodically kind of hashing through their issues, and then breaking for receptions, which is the diplomatic word for party, as it turns out. and sort of methodically kind of hashing through their issues and then breaking for
其中一次聚会。是的，2015年在日内瓦，世界气象大会是每四年一次的大型活动，这是世界各地的天气外交官聚在一起，有条不紊地梳理他们的问题，然后休息参加招待会，事实证明这是派对的外交用语。
receptions, which is the diplomatic word for party, as it turns out. It's mostly very specific and technical, but the dynamic between the countries that essentially run super computers and the countries that don't was increasingly apparent and not surprisingly, the effects of climate change are more pronounced for less wealthy countries, which is also the countries that don't fly whether satellites and run whether super computers. So there was really a sense that they were all in it together that this was a kind of thing that governments did.
招待会，事实证明这是派对的外交用语。这主要是非常具体和技术性的，但拥有超级计算机的国家和没有超级计算机的国家之间的动态越来越明显，而且不出所料，气候变化的影响对不太富裕的国家更为显著，这些国家也是不发射气象卫星和运行气象超级计算机的国家。所以确实有一种感觉，他们都在一起，这是政府做的一种事情。
And there was 150-year tradition of governments around the world sharing their data with each know, sharing their data with each other, sharing their forecasts with each other. And especially now, when storms are more powerful, when the effects of those storms are more pronounced, when there is this sort of growing threat of what will happen with the weather in the future, it was very clear that that cooperation
而且世界各地的政府有150年的传统，分享他们的数据，分享他们的预报。特别是现在，当风暴更强大，当这些风暴的影响更显著，当未来天气会发生什么的威胁日益增长时，很明显这种合作
was needed now more than ever. There's this whole notion of the weather machine, this is this global project, it's carried out by governments, it's done for the public good, but increasingly, private companies are getting into the weather forecasting business. So tell us about that and how this is interacting
现在比以往任何时候都更需要。有整个天气机器的概念，这是一个全球项目，由政府执行，为了公共利益而做，但越来越多的私营公司正在进入天气预报业务。所以告诉我们关于这一点，以及它是如何与
with the sort of global project that's been going on for decades and decades. Yeah, well, there has been the assumption, essentially, since the birth of satellites and computers, that super computers and satellites are things that governments do. They're too expensive for private companies to do. If you have a weather service, you know, and you need a $30 million computer, that's going to be something that a government buys and it's going to be in service not only to its citizens,
几十年来一直在进行的全球项目相互作用的。是的，嗯，基本上自从卫星和计算机诞生以来，人们就一直认为超级计算机和卫星是政府做的事情。它们对私营公司来说太贵了。如果你有一个气象服务机构，你需要一台3000万美元的计算机，那将是政府购买的东西，它不仅服务于其公民，
but to the entire world. But the couple of current circumstances are colliding. I mean, one, you have the couple of current circle are colliding. I mean, one, you have the sort of rise of private spaceflight. You have the kind of space access of the world, and you have private space observation companies. You have more severe weather and more money at stake to predict that weather.
而且服务于全世界。但目前的几种情况正在碰撞。我的意思是，一方面，你有私营航天事业的兴起。你有世界上的太空准入，你有私营太空观测公司。你有更严重的天气和更多的资金投入来预测这种天气。
And you have a kind of rise of the recognition of big data and what we can do with data and how important it is to understand the world using big data and what we can do with data and how important it is to understand the world using big data. And so you end up now with the idea that private weather forecasting is probably a pretty good business. And so after 150-year tradition of weather forecasting
你有对大数据认识的兴起，以及我们能用数据做什么，以及利用大数据了解世界是多么重要。所以你现在得出的结论是，私人天气预报可能是一门相当不错的生意。因此，在150年的天气预报传统之后
being something that governments do for their citizens, there's now a bit of a gold rush where companies can run their own weather models, can fly their own weather satellites, can collect their own weather observations, and provide a private forecast that is a value that exceeds the usefulness of the publicly available forecast. And how do you think about that as someone who's seen the long view of the weather machine turning towards privatization? Like, what do you think are the complications like now
作为政府为公民做的事情，现在出现了一点淘金热，公司可以运行自己的天气模型，可以发射自己的气象卫星，可以收集自己的天气观测数据，并提供比公开预报更有价值的私人预报。作为一个看到天气机器转向私有化长远前景的人，你是怎么看待这个问题的？你认为现在的复杂性是什么
and maybe the complications in the future? Well, I mean, the first thing that I saw was the real angst among the sort of died in the wool government meteorologists over what this meant for the long tradition of government weather services protecting life and property. And that being something that governments do for their citizens. But of course, from a technical standpoint,
也许未来的复杂性是什么？嗯，我的意思是，我看到的第一件事是那些老派的政府气象学家对这意味着什么感到真正的焦虑，因为政府气象服务保护生命和财产有着悠久的传统。而这正是政府为公民所做的事情。但当然，从技术角度来看，
you have the possibility of even better weather forecasts. And so there's certainly a kind of technological thrill with the idea that this could be improved, but it's not hard to recognize the kind of global inequality suddenly appearing in the technology of the weather forecast itself, and this real exacerbation of the effects of climate change when you have hurricane forecasts accessible to the rich before they are accessible to the poor. When, of course, they will affect the most vulnerable more directly.
你有获得更好天气预报的可能性。所以，这种技术进步的想法肯定有一种技术上的快感，但很容易识别出天气预报技术本身突然出现的全球不平等，以及当你让富人在穷人之前获得飓风预报时，气候变化影响的这种真正加剧。当然，它们会更直接地影响最脆弱的人群。
Yeah. We get to the sort of the crux of this, which is like, at this moment, being aware of the new extremes when it comes to our climate is more important than ever, we're at this moment where, you know, privatization and proprietary data and models could break that apart. And it wouldn't take much as the sort of strange thing. All the weather observations that are collected by the US government are put, it's kind of right
是的。我们谈到了这个问题的核心，即在这一刻，意识到我们气候的新极端比以往任何时候都更重要，我们正处于这样一个时刻，私有化和专有数据及模型可能会打破这种局面。而且这不需要太多，这是一种奇怪的事情。美国政府收集的所有天气观测数据都被放入了
in the global bucket. And in exchange, we get all the world's weather observations that are collected by the US government are put, it's kind of right in the global bucket. And in exchange, we get all the world's weather observations back. And if, for example, the National Weather Service decides to buy private satellite observations for one category, and that company says, no, you can't share that, and that's big it has turned off, the possibility that other, you know, start with European countries will say, well, if you're not giving us that data, we're not giving you our data. And within two or three days, you know, the entire system falls apart. And it's not as if, well, we only need observations over the United States for forecasts over the
全球桶中。作为交换，我们得到了世界所有的天气观测数据。如果，例如，国家气象局决定为某一类别购买私人卫星观测数据，而那家公司说，不，你不能分享那个，而那个被关闭了，其他欧洲国家可能会说，好吧，如果你不给我们那些数据，我们也不会给你我们的数据。两三天内，整个系统就会崩溃。而且并不是说，好吧，我们只需要美国上空的观测数据来进行
United States. As soon as you're passing a three or four days, you need that entire global view. And all of the weather models are kind of built on that holistic global view. And so the idea that this is a kind of, you know, this is within our borders, that this is a kind of local issue, that it isn't entirely international, interdependent, is preposterous. And of course, it's deep in the kind of global order
美国的预报。一旦你超过三四天，你就需要那种全球视野。所有的天气模型都是建立在这种整体全球视野之上的。所以认为这是一个在我们边界之内的问题，这是一个地方性问题，它不是完全国际化、相互依存的，这是荒谬的。当然，它深深植根于
that the US built up in the second half of the 20th century. You know, it is the kind of American ideal of leading the world with technology and cooperation. And at the moment, and not only in the Trump era, but really over the last 10 years, particularly with the kind of new technological dominance of the US, with the Googles and Facebooks of the world,
美国在20世纪下半叶建立的全球秩序中。你知道，这是美国用技术和合作引领世界的理想。目前，不仅是在特朗普时代，而且在过去10年里，特别是随着美国新的技术主导地位，随着谷歌和Facebook这样的公司，
that the idea of the sort of proprietaryness of this data as something that is deep in the heart of our system becomes more consequential in the way that we put together weather forecasts. Yeah. I think one of the things that's fascinating about all this and all the work that you've done and my thinking on it that has evolved since reading your book is this weird mixing of the idea of weather and knowing the weather being so kind of the idea of whether and knowing the weather, being so kind of the now and every day, and how much it's about little tiny decisions about whether you bring an umbrella,
这种数据作为我们系统核心深处的东西的专有性概念，在我们整合天气预报的方式中变得更加重要。是的。我认为关于这一切以及你所做的所有工作，以及我自阅读你的书以来对此演变的思考，最迷人的一点是天气和了解天气的想法与这种非常当下的、日常的、关于你是否带伞的小决定，
and also about hurricanes, it kind of gets your mind reeling in this very strange way about just like the human desire to know what's coming. Yeah, yeah. This book took me several years to write, and in the course of writing it, my older child, my daughter, went from kind of a toddler to like a proper elementary school student. And at the beginning, I would be working on this
以及关于飓风的混合，它以一种非常奇怪的方式让你的大脑旋转，关于人类想要知道未来会发生什么的渴望。是的，是的。这本书我写了好几年，在写作过程中，我的大孩子，我的女儿，从一个蹒跚学步的孩子变成了一个正式的小学生。起初，我会做这个
and she would say, what's it going to be tomorrow? Like that would be kind of her last words before going to sleep. She meant like, what are we doing? But I would be like, oh, how do you consider the future? What does it mean that the sky is coming this way? And I'm sort of rooted in place and time and how is this going on?
她会说，明天会怎么样？就像那是她睡觉前的最后一句话。她的意思是，我们要去做什么？但我会说，哦，你是怎么考虑未来的？天空以这种方式到来意味着什么？我被植根于地点和时间，这怎么会发生？
And so I kind of heard it as like, what's the weather going to be tomorrow? And that sort of contrast between my watch is going to tell me what the weather is going to be tomorrow. And that's just super easy and no worries. And then the existential dread of what's it going to be tomorrow was right there with it. It's the most banal thing. It is the ultimate small talk.
所以我把它听成是，明天的天气会怎么样？那种对比，我的手表会告诉我明天的天气会怎么样。这超级简单，不用担心。然后对明天会怎么样的存在主义恐惧就在那里。这是最平庸的事情。这是终极的闲聊。
And yet it's also, of course, the core of our existential planetary dread. And this isn't some way the sort of parable of climate change as well. We can be pretty sure about what's going to happen and the ability to change it or to do something about it is completely independent of that foresight. In other words, we have the information.
然而，它当然也是我们存在主义行星恐惧的核心。这在某种程度上也是气候变化的寓言。我们可以相当确定会发生什么，而改变它或对此采取行动的能力完全独立于这种远见。换句话说，我们拥有信息。
We can effectively see into the future, but what we do with that information and how it is used for planning and preparation is up to us. To find out more about Andrew Blum's book, The Weather Machine. Go to nyanipi.org. We're going to visit a tiny island in the North Atlantic that is a tiny cog in the gigantic weather machine after this. One of the most fascinating things about the entire system used to protect the weather is how reliant it is on space aid satellites orbiting the Earth and hundreds of more humble weather stations located on the land. Both technologies are needed to inform our global view, because the weather machine is so vast and made of so many parts, no one thing exemplifies it all.
我们可以有效地看到未来，但我们如何利用这些信息以及它如何用于规划和准备取决于我们。要了解更多关于Andrew Blum的《天气机器》一书的信息，请访问nyanipi.org。之后，我们将访问北大西洋的一个小岛，它是巨大天气机器中的一个小齿轮。保护天气的整个系统最迷人的地方之一是它对绕地球运行的太空卫星和位于陆地上的数百个更卑微的气象站的依赖。两种技术都需要为我们的全球视野提供信息，因为天气机器太庞大，由太多部分组成，没有哪一件事能完全体现它。
But I asked Andrew Blum if he could zoom in on one of his favorite places that's essential to the whole data gathering apparatus. When you try to kind of peel open the weather machine and see what it's made of, you end up with this kind of challenge of choosing a single place to represent all the places, which of course is kind of impossible. You know, it is the nature of places that they are all different, so they all occupy a kind of different spot in the map, partly because of Birkenis and partly because of this Norwegian meteorological tradition,
但我问Andrew Blum，他是否可以放大他最喜欢的地方之一，这对整个数据收集装置至关重要。当你试图剥开天气机器看看它是由什么组成时，你会面临选择一个地方来代表所有地方的挑战，这当然是不可能的。你知道，地方的本质是它们都是不同的，所以它们都在地图上占据不同的位置，部分是因为比耶克内斯，部分是因为这种挪威气象传统，
I latched on to Norway's system of weather observation. And in fact, I fell completely in love with this island called Yan Mayan. That's this Arctic island way off, kind of towards Greenland, that only has a weather station on it with an army crew, they get serviced a few times a year and a couple huskies, and it sounds like this really kind of incredible wild place. Which means this to say you can't go there,
我迷上了挪威的天气观测系统。事实上，我完全爱上了这个叫扬马延（Jan Mayen）的岛屿。那是一个北极岛屿，离格陵兰岛很远，上面只有一个气象站，有一支军队人员，他们一年被服务几次，还有几只哈士奇，听起来像是一个非常不可思议的野外地方。这意味着你不能去那里，
if you go, you have to go for three months. So I kind of abandoned that dream of actually visiting this weather station, but found instead a place called Ducira, which is a sort of small island off the coast of Norway, and when I say off the coast of Norway, I mean, it's like a 25-minute ferry ride, like, you know, no big deal, it runs a few times a day, but because of its location in the North Sea, it has been an important weather observation point, basically for 150 years. And so you have a very early telegraph line there, and you have a single spot kind of up on
如果你要去，就得待上三个月。所以我放弃了去那个气象站的梦想，转而找到了一个叫乌齐拉（Utsira）的地方，那是挪威海岸外的一个小岛。我说在挪威海岸外，是指坐渡轮只要25分钟，没什么大不了的，一天有几班船。但由于它位于北海，150年来它一直是重要的气象观测点。那里有很早期的电报线路，还有一个点位于
the top of the hill in the center of the island that consistently has been the point where the Norwegian Weather Service has observed the weather. It's a very windy place, which is known for its birding and for its winds. And when you're there, you realize, I realized what it meant for the kind of win to be rushing by this single point. And I realized that that's kind of what win is. You know, win is the passage of the atmosphere, past a single spot. And you know, that has to then be tied back into the kind of global computational system.
岛中心山顶上，挪威气象局一直都在那里观测天气。那是个风很大的地方，以观鸟和强风闻名。当你身处那里时，你会意识到，我意识到风从这个单一地点掠过意味着什么。我意识到这就是风的本质。你知道，风就是大气经过某一个特定地点。而这必须与全球计算系统联系起来。
You know, you need to sort of send word back to Oslo and Oslo needs to send word back to Frankfurt where the sort of European collector is, and then that gets sent to Virginia, and the entire thing kind of gets networked together into typing in Utsiro and Google, and then the temperature shows up. But all of those things have to fit together, and that system has to be deliberately designed,
你需要把信息传回奥斯陆，奥斯陆再传回欧洲数据收集中心所在的法兰克福，然后发送到弗吉尼亚，整个系统联网在一起。在谷歌搜索乌齐拉，气温就会显示出来。但所有这些环节都必须衔接在一起，而且这个系统必须经过精心设计，
and the kind of design of that system goes back to the middle of the 19th century with the sort of first recognition that not only was it useful to know what the weather was in other places, but it was suddenly technologically possible to get that news pretty speedily. Right. And it's gathered by a human or tended to by a human, you know. It's tended to by a human. Yeah, he runs the restaurant and he does the weather observations.
而这种系统的设计可以追溯到19世纪中叶，当时人们不仅认识到了解其他地方的天气很有用，而且突然在技术上也有可能迅速获得这些消息。没错。而且这些数据是由人类收集或维护的，你知道的。是由人类维护的。是的，他经营着一家餐馆，同时也负责气象观测。
So it's four times a day, he goes on his back stoop and he has a cigarette and he kind of looks at the sky. And then he goes to his computer and he logs in and he in the kind of Norwegian weather services drop down menus. He sort of does a qualitative analysis of what the clouds are according to the sort of rules that he's been taught. And that gets then sort of put in the whole way. And the same thing happens in every airport, in the country, every major airport has around the clock weather observer, some person who's in an office somewhere on the grounds of the airport, who once an hour is checking
所以他每天四次走到后门廊，抽根烟，看看天空。然后他回到电脑前登录挪威气象局的下拉菜单。他根据所学的规则对云层进行定性分析。然后这些数据被输入到整个系统中。全国的每个机场也是如此，每个主要机场都有全天候的气象观测员，某个在机场办公室内的人，每小时检查一次
the observations that the automated system has made to make sure the system's working, and if the clouds are slightly different than the Celieter, the cloud observing machine can read to correct those. Andrew Blum is the author of the Weather Machine, a journey inside the forecast. 99% of visible was produced this week by Delaney Hall, Mix and Tech Production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Riel.
自动化系统所做的观测，以确保系统正常工作。如果云层与云高仪（自动观测云层的机器）读取的数据略有不同，他会进行修正。安德鲁·布鲁姆（Andrew Blum）是《气象机器：预报之旅》（The Weather Machine, a journey inside the forecast）一书的作者。《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）本周由德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）制作，混音和技术制作由谢丽·福塞夫（Sheree Fusef）负责，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。
Our senior producer is Katie Mangle, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, thrust the team as Emmith Fitzgerald, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroube, Avery Trouffleman, Sophia Klotzger, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K AW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective
我们的高级制作人是凯蒂·曼格尔（Katie Mangle），库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监，团队成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emith Fitzgerald）、薇薇安·勒（Vivian Le）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffleman）、索菲亚·克洛茨格（Sophia Klotzger），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW广播电台的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的广播街（Radio Row）制作。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，这是一个极其独立的集体，
of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radtopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or on Instagram and Reddit too. But we should really talk about the weather at 99PI.org. Radio Topea.
汇集了播客界最具创新性的节目。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解所有节目。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我 @RomanMars，关注节目 @99PI，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上关注我们。但我们真的应该在 99PI.org 上聊聊天气。RadioTopia。
From PRX. Radio Tepi-A from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。RadioTopia，来自PRX。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。